kick your [ __ ] up ur ass you
[ __ ] worthless
hey everybody welcome to the 13 o'clock
podcast episode 1111 already I know
right it seems like just yesterday we
started this podcast ya know shows
growing yes shout out to all our new
subscribers yeah we're up to about 60 on
Facebook yeah Justin on Facebook YouTube
yeah and the podcast section is
evidently doing pretty good too so yeah
you know takes a while to grow a channel
but the channels need to be growing we
have fans yeah thanks you guys and
Jenny's actually considering making some
t-shirts yeah some cool 13 o'clock
t-shirts a probably one of them will
definitely have to be our black logo it
says 13 on it and it has me and you on
it yeah I would like to do one like that
and I'd also like to do like kind of
themed ones yeah I'd be cool with all
the different shows yeah yeah yeah you
have like a UH like a Braille version
yeah from the Nazi show we did last week
yeah and then you could do like a serial
killer version yeah maybe like the the
original Nightstalker shirt something
like that yeah each that way I want a
satanic panic wasn't an ionic yeah oh
actually since I said mention satanic
panic that's a good segue into our topic
today oh that's right because today
we're talking about
Damon's casted out the Damon's you never
know man demon might just appear might
go inside you yeah that's kind of kind
of yes we're talking about casting out
demons we're talking about quote-unquote
supposedly real cases of demonic
possession and exorcisms yeah now one of
them even has the Warrens in it and
Lorraine Warren yeah what are they I
don't know if I'm gonna give like a huge
like thing of that okay just gonna I'll
just mention that wherever those two
around that's where the demons are
that's what I mean yeah cuz I actually
made a meme of them like the picture
two of them and said I'm not saying it's
demons footed statements instead of the
Greek alien guy yeah cuz everywhere they
go
yeah shit's damaged yeah but okay so
before we get started full disclosure
I'm I'm an atheist I do not believe
demons exist okay so whatever these
cases of possession or exorcism for
things like that are I think it's
probably one of three things one the
kids acting out just being an [ __ ]
right two kids got mental problems three
could be some poltergeist activity that
is being misidentified as demon
possession that's gonna upset some
atheists I think and some religious
people cuz I'm an atheist also but I've
actually witnessed what would be called
I think we've mentioned on the show
before we don't think poltergeist
activity is supernatural no I think it's
I think has something to do with quantum
physics some kind of exotic physics and
I've had near-death experience I believe
there's an afterlife yeah
not necessarily the heaven that's that's
talked about in religions but for damn
close from you know if you have an NDE
it's a dreamlike experience which is
weird but yeah that's for another show
I think there's demons though do you
Dixon here is that in person here's the
thing we're we're gonna do a show about
demonic possession yeah and you have
these people saying that well you know
I'm witnessing demons but what are
demons because they're if you're gonna
if you're gonna go by the Bible the Old
Testament the New Testament they're not
really clear on what a demon is yeah I
mean in Genesis you have el shaddai or
God God Almighty
and his sons some of those sons have sex
with the daughters of men and and from
them come Nephilim rif am a ref alum
that has mentioned it in other parts of
the Old Testament and then Giants and
men of great renown right some of them
some of these sons of God are chained up
into the earth they never really call
them demons
but in Christian tradition they will say
that those are demons and then in the
New Testament you have the stories of
Jesus going into graveyards to cast
demons out of a possessed man yeah and
he throws them in a pig and a pig right
and they jump up well why are demons in
the cemetery are they talking are they
talking about the souls of the Evil Dead
so what is a demon a fallen angel or is
it souls of the Evil Dead right it's not
real it's not real clear and it was
definitely is not clear in the original
text no in the original Greek text and
even so what is a demon yeah that's you
know it's unclear right good but so the
first case we're gonna talk about is
probably one of the better known ones um
everyone in the world has probably seen
the Exorcist yeah and not the TV show
the original movie obviously um they
start a real case and that is based on a
real case um based on the novel by
William Peter Blatty which came out in
1971 and William Peter Blatty actually
got the idea for writing the extras from
a newspaper article that he read about
an actual exorcism and strangely enough
other than the actual kid being a boy
and not a girl um most of the most of
the [ __ ] that happened in the movie was
pretty close to what was reported in the
actual case yes clergy witnessed it yeah
and and people that were not in the
clergy witnessed it but it went on a lot
longer yeah great what they show the
movie yeah and it followed the kid
around because they moved him around a
lot yeah it actually it actually took
place in Maryland
it started in cottage city and it was
1949 and the kid was 13 years old now I
don't think his real name has ever been
revealed usually when people talk about
the case he's referred to by a pseudonym
either Roland doe or Robbie Manheim so
but those those are not his name I don't
know
his real name is but basically so the
kid he was kind of a kind of a weird kid
a little bit of a loner type of kid and
didn't get along with his parents
evidently only close family member his
aunt Harriet now in 1949 his aunt
Harriet gave him a Ouija board just like
in the movie just like in the movie and
not long after what she died so the kid
missed her and so started trying to
communicate with her on the Ouija board
and the Ouija board apparently get gave
some answers and [ __ ] like that so you
know he's thinking oh and Harriet's
communicating with me and then just like
in the movie weird [ __ ] started
happening around the house they start
here and all these weird like footsteps
like marching across the seat across the
ceiling or up in there I remember that
yes crouching at the wall right pictures
vibrating on the wall and objects like
rattling on shelves and stuff like that
and you know [ __ ] in the house would be
moved around and also about this time
the kid let's call it let's call him
Robbie because that's one of his names I
don't want to keep saying the kid the
possessed kid so then he started
complaining just like in the movie that
his bed was shaking and that his covers
were coming off you know what he's lying
off or being pulled off him okay so he
complains to his family about this as
she would it's like hey I was weird
shits happening mom and dad how old was
he again at 13 13 13 typical yep and
initially I mean it's fair play to his
parents I guess they did believe him but
they thought that the disturbances were
caused by aunt Harriet the ghost of aunt
Harriet okay so they kind of started to
try to communicate with her you know by
like asking questions and hey knock
three times four yes a bloody block and
Knox would come out of the wall and Knox
would come out of the wall so they
thought Oh aunt Harriet's talking to us
but then [ __ ] got a little weirder
um you know the bed would shake all the
time which was he would just be sitting
on it still on the bed would shake and
this was just witnessed by other family
men it's not just reporting yeah and
then like unexplained scratches started
appearing on his arms a weird rash
appeared on his abdomen that apparently
said he'll and you know just like in the
movie I think it said I think it's at
help and the movie didn't it but um so
so then they figured oh well maybe it's
not an hair hit cuz she wouldn't do that
she was a nice lady so they took the kid
to the hospital to get him give him a
physical and mental health workup and
they couldn't find anything wrong right
so then they figure well we'll go to the
church like you do because they didn't
know what else to do and they had a
couple of priests come out and have a
look at the kid not necessarily for an
exorcism at first just to see what the
problem was now according to these two
priests they said that Robbie started
kind of growling and [ __ ] like that and
then he started talking in a language
that well one of the guys there was a
rabbi and that guy said that's Hebrew
Wow and then he started speaking in
another language that they didn't
recognize but when they took the tapes
to some University nearby they said
that's Aramaic Wow so you know that's a
very common aspect of possession that
you could supposedly can talk and no
were they able to understand entire
sentences or they just were these just
broken words yeah as far as I know it
was just kind of broke but the I mean it
was real they were real words I wish
they would have kept that yeah kept the
recording I mean yeah I mean it was so
long ago
right so you know that kind of freaked
him out understandably so then they
called their own pastor whose name was
Luther Schultz and he said well can you
bring the kid to my house and he can
stay here overnight and I'll observe him
and so he takes the kid to his house now
at his house he also started hearing
scratching at the walls and the bed was
vibrate
would vibrate and you know the kid was
sitting in the middle of bed was
vibrating and then so you know the the
pastor is like okay well he tells the
kid to go sleep on a big armchair and in
the bedroom so the goat the kid goes and
gets in the armchair now the pastor said
that as soon as the kid got in the
armchair the chair slid backwards and
then started rocking back and forth with
him in it with the kid in it man how far
did it slide back D say a few inches
like against the wall and then like it
was rocking back and forth and then it
slammed against the wall tipped over and
threw the kid out onto the floor huh
they said there was no way he could have
done that on his own no I mean you know
leverage spots he wasn't pushing with
his feet nothing
yes I mean according to the password you
said it just did it by itself
okay so then he so then the pastor takes
out a blanket puts it on the floor for
the kid to sleep on and then the blanket
flew across the floor and disappeared
under the bed Wow now the pastor said he
had been watching the kid the whole time
and there was no way he could have done
that okay yeah so after that he goes
back to Robbie's family and he says okay
I don't know what's going on maybe you
should take him for another series of
tests maybe they missed something
blah-de-blah so they did that that's
weird though when you think of that he
sees he sees objects moving around and
he says well have the kid checked out
with a doctor that's kind of a weird
that's kind of weird solution to that
problem I don't even think it was a
solution I think it was just kind of
like a shrug like I don't know the
[ __ ] maybe was like get rid of this
kid probably that's probably closer to
the truth yeah because if I saw that
happen I didn't instantly become a
believer okay yep yep that's happening
he's not sick that's some kind of a
demon there's poltergeist to me it
sounds like classic poltergeist so far
yeah yeah yeah which is what I think I
mean if the witness if the witness
accounts are correct sorry I'm drinking
root beer and I'm burping yeah you're
vaping and drinking yeah but you know if
if the witness accounts are legitimate
then I definitely do think and this is
probably it's probably a pole it's
similar to the case that I had because
it wasn't just a case of like a kid
going brah you know there was actual
[ __ ] moving around yeah sorry it's ours
PK yeah recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis right it's unconscious so
so they take him for another series of
tests they don't find anything now this
the pastor also contacted JB Rhine who
very famous percé psychologist from the
Duke Universe I college II Duke
University parapsychology lab okay he's
the one that invented the Zener cards
you know with the little simple heads
okay yeah yeah it's fertility yeah yeah
that guy so he drove drove up from North
Carolina to visit the kid now while Ryan
was there he didn't see anything okay
but he said the same thing we said he
said well if this [ __ ] happened the way
you said then it's RSP K it's
poltergeist activity right it's not
demon possession and then he went back
home but then you know the pastor
started seeing more scratches appearing
on the kids arms and the pastor said
look we need to call in a Catholic
priest to do an exorcism now there are
some things about this story that were
added later or were exaggerated like
there's a story that there was a book
that came out in 1993 like about this
case and this had this story in it but I
don't think this story is genuine they
said in this book it said the kid was
taken to Georgetown University Hospital
to go to have an exorcism right and the
priest that did the exorcism was named
bird Albert Hughes now it said that
during the exorcism
you know Hughes said he's heard the kids
speaking in Latin thrashing around and
then they restrained the kid he broke
free from his restraints Taurus spring
out of the mattress he was lying on and
slashed the priests hand open with it
yeah I remember this and then it said
that the priests had a nervous breakdown
afterward but later research shows that
this probably did not happen they said
that that um Catholic priests did
actually go and meet with the kid on one
occasion but not for an exorcism and he
said I never said that the kid spoke
Latin in my present and he said when I
met with him was at a church it wasn't
even at a hospital I was not injured and
he he never had a nervous breakdown
either he had a normal you know he had a
normal thing in his church st. James
Church and then he died in 1980 and it
was also he just met the kid but nothing
weird yeah he just met the kid but
nothing right happened okay and um okay
so so that probably never happened but
then they say put the kid in the
hospital again
and now people at the hospital like
staff and stuff like that they said they
saw the words appearing on the kids
flesh yeah it said hell I think there's
one said evil and [ __ ] like that
so um and I said it looked like you know
you had like claw marks all over him
yeah one account I heard from a guy who
was I believe at the time he was an
altar boy yeah I was helping these
priests do this ISM and he'd looked down
he'd see things appear on the kid rashes
and he thought at one time he could see
faces and shapes and was trying to
interpret them and he caught he he
called it to the attention of the priest
that was doing the exercise look at that
what does that say what is that is that
a face and the guy just went don't read
into things
ignore it yeah cuz they didn't you know
he wasn't encouraging him to read into
anything they were just
get the exorcism done weird I believe
the guy to get these damn demons out of
here yeah so after Robbie got out of the
hospital his mother thought well maybe
you know a change of scenery will help
alright so he takes she takes the kid to
st. Louis to stay with some of her
relatives and supposedly the phenomenon
is continuing all this time yes okay
because actually his mother was from st.
Louis so he took sue so she took him to
st. Louis and it the lettering on his
skin actually on the on his stomach
spelled out Louis his mother saw it
Louis yeah come across his stomach and
also she said when they got to st. Louis
they were talking about you know whether
they should enroll him in school there
or something like that and the word no
appeared on his wrists weird yeah so I'm
just kind of stigmata yeah that's
exactly what it sounds like
like psychosomatic symptom yeah yeah
that's what I think it is probably now
the [ __ ] did not get any better in st.
Louis same should happen bed vibrations
he was getting scratches and words
compute you know appearing on his skin
furniture was moving around [ __ ] like
that and this was seen by family members
as well as Reverend Reverend bishop who
came to look at the kid and actually
bishop when he was at the house he
sprinkled some holy water on the kid and
then the kid started to crying and
screaming and then there was like a big
zigzag like wound where the word of holy
water went right so okay and there was
also two of the priests the two of the
priests came back our Bishop came back
and he had another priest with him named
Reverend Bowden and they're here they
had some kind of significant RSP k [ __ ]
it's like they heard all this banging
coming from Robbie's room so they ran up
there and they said
this huge huge bookcase that had been
turned all the way around chair had been
overturned and the kid was sitting on
the bed and it was like shaking really
violently huh so these two priests saw
this and said this we need to do a
[ __ ] exorcism like yesterday
so they went an appeal to get one and it
was actually granted they didn't give
him any problems about it so they did
the exorcism it took a while to do they
did it like three separate locations
you know the house the relative's house
where Robbie was staying there was a
place called the Alexian Brothers
Hospital in st. Louis and the rectory at
st. Francis Xavier Church and they don't
know exactly like records have kind of
been lost about how many witnesses there
were at each one but there were several
at each one priest seminary students and
other observers who were not necessarily
with the church so the the exorcism that
happened it happened pretty close to how
it did in the movie like not as I don't
think he puked or anything like that but
he he smelled real bad like he kept
emitting like weird noxious odors and
things like that well you know I had to
bring okay hey you already said
something about demons getting inside
you all right so so the same [ __ ] kind
of happened to me like [ __ ] like you
know words appeared on his stomach like
spite and things like that spoke in
different languages growled spewed
profanity and also like in the movie he
knew facts about the priest that they
don't think he could possibly have known
Wow which was kind of weird did they
mention any no no actually I take it
that way they're like Shh
yeah brought up that issue with that
altar boy yeah yeah although that was
probably thought by Deven just a lucky
guess I know that because all of you do
that stop it yeah okay so I guess I
guess he did vomit and he peed on
himself and all kind of stuff yeah all
kind of stuff and they also said that he
distorted his body in ways that didn't
seem physically possible weird now one
of the priests said that he saw the kid
flying through the air and saw him
vaporize a ritual book like Shh
Oh vaporized that's the word he used you
got a cut in you got a cut in the air do
not despise my command because you know
God Himself the majestic Christ just I
will put that in now that's kind of
spooky what you think about it though
yeah that's a pretty intense poltergeist
outburst yeah it yeah it was so and this
is what I think was do what I think
happened is because priests were
involved the power of suggestion there
tell them that this is a demon and you
need to be demonic demonically possessed
you need to be exorcised yeah that the
poltergeist phenomena manifested as
demonic possession that's what I'm
thinking because evidently he would also
go into trance-like states and vast
dates and and I mean his family and his
family I should say was pretty religious
yeah I had heard that the kid actually
who's Jewish who married into a Lutheran
family he didn't want to go to that
church he was he wanted to go to
synagogue yeah his mother married a
Christian guy and his stepdad wanted to
that's how that's how I remember that's
just from memory yeah
okay so so they kept doing the exorcism
it took you know I don't even know over
several weeks or something like that
they took the kid back to Maryland but
the church is there like [ __ ] bad noise
so you went back to st. Louis they took
him to a Jesuit retreat called the White
House while he was there apparently he
tried to jump off a cliff yeah they had
to stop yeah and then a guy had to
tackle on I remember that yeah so you
know kid was messed up this is what
we're saying so they kept doing it
nothing seemed to be helping then one of
the priests says well I'm gonna
put like all these religious medals and
stuff like all over the kid like you put
them all over his neck and he stuff the
cross in his hands and stuff like that
and that actually seemed to calm the kid
down and the kids started asking the
priest about the prayers but then the
priest kept praying and ignored his
questions and then he got pissed off and
then he just started thrashing around
and freaking out and they had to
restrain him but um so evidently it's
kind of weird because they didn't do
anything particularly different like
other than the metals thing but
apparently that kind of worked in the
end huh so you know the one the one
priest just kind of kept saying stuff
over a man and then they wore him out
yeah I guess so and then Robbie kept
saying I'm a fallen angel I'm a fallen
angel and then they said and then the
witnesses said that a man's voice came
out of the kid announcing he was Michael
the Archangel awesome and was commanding
the demon to depart man I wish I could
see that right yeah and then they said
his body kind of distorted a little bit
and then he was fine cool and then he
sat up and smiled and he's like hey I'm
free yeah ever all right and then yeah
so later he moved back to Maryland and
it's nothing ever happened to him again
which Catholic High School got married
had three kids lives in DC what's the
analysis the analysis of this yeah the
parapsychology is where they would hire
psychologists wouldn't they say all
right speaking our speaker yeah okay
because like I said not just a case of a
mentally ill run kid acting out because
people did see [ __ ] moving around right
it's a psychic temper tantrum he did
believe he was possessed so that's how
you manifested it right all right she
did believe that the Archangel Michael
saved him and that yeah that's what
ended it that's how he justified the end
of thee yeah poltergeist fit but like
you said he was probably just worn out
at the worn out good day because they
kept taking him back and forth
everywhere and they just kept praying
over him a boy he's probably like sick
of it yeah well it's kind of like
breaking the kids will yeah yeah knock
it off knock
well actually let's take a break okay
we're gonna take one of our three breaks
at the moment and then we will come back
and we're going to talk about the very
sad case of Anneliese Michele which I
think was actually I think the cause of
that not so much our spk I think the
cause of that was tragically untreated
mental illness yeah these are both
well-known cases where a start with the
with a with the well no but okay so
we're gonna take a little break right
now and we'll be right back I would like
to take a second and thank subculture
corsets in clothing for sponsoring
project I radio and my show while
listening to my podcast please take a
second and visit their website at
www.att.com/biz gothic steampunk and pin
up clothing shoes and accessories again
their website is subculture corsets calm
or if you're in the Jacksonville Florida
area stop by their store in The Avenues
Mall and if you like to save money use
the discount code 13 o'clock when
checking out and save 10% off your
entire order by the way if you're a
curvy girl subculture do not forget
about you they carry size 4 to 4 X and
guys they have men's clothing and shoes
as well so go shop at subculture corsets
calm now and use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount ok so you
guys probably saw the movie The Exorcism
of Emily Rose from 2005 I didn't see it
actually I just saw it for the first
time the other day because it was on
cable was any good it was that right ok
it wasn't actually what I expected all
right but not really so much a horror
movie but but the chick from Dexter was
in it so that was read oh I did see that
yeah you said I think you didn't like
yes I think but yeah so that was
actually based on a real person she was
a German girl named Anneliese Michelle
and this happened in the seventies 1975
now this one
this is kind of sucks because this girl
she was from a super super religious
family very devout Catholic she was born
in 1952 and um you know she was real
religious growing up not like in a in a
creepy you know carry carry carry kind
of way yeah but just in a real they said
she was real compassionate real
intelligent I guess and she was always
praying and very pious so but there was
kind of but her parents were real strict
Catholics and there was kind of like a
you know skeletons in the closet like
before um
Anneliese was born four years before she
was born her mother had an illegitimate
daughter like she got knocked up before
her and the husband were married and
apparently in the I mean in the Catholic
you know world that was very those big
no no okay so sad like even when even
when she married the husband they made
her wear a black wedding veil ooh
so everyone would know like here's you
know it was like a stigma so and then
the sad thing is that um the
illegitimate kid who was you know
Annalise's older sister she actually
died which he was 8 years old huh so you
know not not a real happy kind of
childhood I guess but um so they kind of
think that maybe the way Annalise was
that she was real religious and you know
as as happened in the movie she almost
wanted to like take on people's sins
like a martyr um so they think that
might have contributed that she was
almost trying to expiate her mother's
sins because she saw how ashamed
her mother was and she wanted to make it
better Wow okay so they think that's
kind of the psychology that was going on
there but the sad thing is that Annalise
seemed pretty normal you know other than
being pretty religious pretty normal kid
intelligent did real good in school you
know it was a real nice girl and stuff
like that and then in 1968 when she was
16 she
started having convulsions and so she
went to a neurologist in 1970 and they
said that she had temporal lobe epilepsy
and they put her on medication now the
first medication she was given was
delance and that's an anticonvulsant and
that didn't help her and actually after
they put her on that it almost seemed to
get worse like she started saying that
she was hearing voices she was seeing
devil faces like appearing on the wall
and um and also they said she had some
physical symptoms like she seemed to
have trouble walking with her balance
and things like that she had some body
dysmorphia she thought that her hands
had turned black and were swelling up
and things like that but they but they
weren't no and then they put her on
another drug called a ellipse I think
I'm pronouncing that right and that's
what they usually give to schizophrenic
right but that didn't help her either
so um even though she was having kind of
all these health problems she finished
high school in 1973 and she went on to
college she went to the University of
verts Berg she was going to become a
teacher and when she was in college the
edges started getting worse and worse
and worse I mean she started getting
depression she was seeing hallucinations
and you know she was in and out of
psychiatric hospitals and it really
didn't seem to be helping her and so
because the medications were not helping
her and it seemed to be getting worse
she got the idea that she was possessed
by demons no was there any did they
report any kind of RS PK or any psychic
phenomena no that's kind of what's sad
about this and this just looks like
mental illness yeah okay but you know
it's kind of sad because what if so she
thought she was possessed by demons okay
now she has if she also had a family
friend and they took they went on this
pilgrimage to to Italy and this family
friend also thought that Anneliese was
possessed because they said you know she
couldn't walk past
crosses she smelled really bad all this
kind of stuff and you know they tried to
get her to drink the holy water and she
couldn't or she wouldn't or whatever so
so she gets back home and her parents
were like yeah it's totally possessed by
demons we want to get her an exorcism
now the church initially said no because
they thought no this is a medical issue
she should keep with her medications and
this would be better managed you know by
a medical intervention so she was still
taking her medications and they had
given her a bunch of other ones like an
anti-psychotic and an anti-seizure but
it wasn't really helping like her
bizarre her behavior was just getting
more and more bizarre so she started
getting like super hostile super
aggressive it's like she kept like
[ __ ] you know bashing on religious
objects and and then after a while she
started just like crawling on the floor
like screaming and barking and peeing on
the floor and drinking it and eating
insects and stuff like that yeah there's
actually recordings at her voice yeah
they're pretty frequently yeah well yeah
I'll actually be I'll actually put one
in here oh yeah okay all right well all
right so here's here's one of the
recordings right here
we don't
yeah yeah that's weird so uh yeah pretty
freaky and pretty sad like considering
how this case turned out but uh so yeah
finally her behavior was just getting so
crazy that a priest came and examined
her and said yeah he thought she was
possessed and he petitioned the local
bishop and said please can we have an
exorcism and the church finally said
that they could so the priests that they
said could give the exorcism was named
Arnold Renz and they said you can do it
but you have to keep it a secret hmm
because in Germany the Catholic Church
of the time they're like you know they
wanted to get away from from from from
exorcisms because they wanted to be seen
as more modern or what happy everyone so
they're like we don't want everybody
knowing that we still do [ __ ] exorcism
so don't tell anybody but um so they
they did the first one in September of
1975 and after they started doing the
exorcisms
Anneliese stopped taking her medications
and her family would not have any more
medical treatment for her because they
just put all their faith in the priest
and said she's got demons get him out so
you know they so they do the exorcisms
she's doing she's doing all the standard
exorcism or the standard possession [ __ ]
she's growling she's contorting she's
talking in languages that she supposedly
doesn't know she's talking in what
sounds like several voices at once like
a bunch of voices are coming out of her
and some of the demons identified
themselves and this is also pretty weird
and pretty common in possession cases in
cases where people are possessed by
demons in a lot of cases they will say
the demons will say you know they're
Lucifer obviously Judas as Judas
Iscariot
which I thought was kind of odd not a
demon yeah Kain okay
yeah Cain in some interpretations of the
Old Testament dr. Robert M price talks
about this Cain
his father possibly could have been a
demon and sir yeah and in the original
yeah yeah edited out right okay yeah
I've heard that oh and also Nero Nero
weird which seems like kind of an odd
sort of I think insane to believe that
Nero was the Antichrist at one time so
yeah that's probably where that comes
from but um I think I've also seen a
couple say they were Hitler but I don't
think she didn't but um yeah Nerra so
they did exorcisms they did a total of
67 exorcisms dang over the next 10
months exorcism marathon it was yeah I
mean it took a long time but they did a
bunch of them um and she just kept
getting worse and worse she what she
would do
they said that she would you know
genuflect you know she get down on her
knees to pray right they said she did
that so much that she tore the ligaments
in her knees words like so she you know
what I mean so yeah she had ruptured
ligaments in her knees and then near the
end of the ten month period she started
to refuse food and water huh because she
said that if she fasted it would help it
would make the demons come out all right
okay I guess like they didn't want to
hang around if they weren't getting any
food or something like that so she so
she lost a lot of weight obviously and
um and the sad thing is that you know in
periods where she was lucid she started
telling the priests and her family that
she was being made to suffer for the
sins of others huh like she was a martyr
and she was saying it was hard but you
know it was that's what she wanted to do
or I don't know if she kept saying word
show yeah up to this point no reports of
any kind of psychic phenomenon no except
maybe talking in languages that she
didn't know right now did she ever make
any claims or predictions that came not
that I know of so like I said I think
this is more a case of of mental
probably mental illness than possession
possession I the human mind is pretty
powerful yeah you could hear a formal
language and maybe repeat a few words of
it later just by memory yeah your
subconscious maybe it could also be
aware of random mumbo-jumbo gibberish
like you hear in the recordings yeah he
interpreted as another language yeah any
words that's probably just random I bet
you she wasn't speaking in any kind of
form probably not that she didn't know
yeah I think it was just what they call
Rorschach test where you just don't love
stuff yeah yeah and you interpret what
you see it's probably like that yeah but
anyway you know she had all these kind
of you know ideas about murder demand
and all this other kind of stuff and she
actually ended up dying yeah July 1976
she was 23 years old when she died she
weighed 68 yes I think that was temporal
lobe epilepsy that is what it sounds
like I'm not a doctor yeah but some
people say that people that have that
can have like weird mental states that
where they feel like they're channeling
yeah those spirits and that they're
seeing the future prophesying yeah and
then then you mix that with maybe
schizophrenia yeah and and super
religiosity is also a hallmark of
temporal lobe epilepsy it is yeah right
so so since she ended up dying and
because she ended up dying of
malnutrition and dehydration so because
her parents had ceased medical treatment
they were arrested yeah and so were two
of the priests that attended the
exorcism they were free dinner yeah so
so there was a big trial just like and
it's pretty similar to what happened in
the movie so you know the whole idea
behind the trial was they weren't I mean
the priests were saying yeah she was
possessed by demons and this is how this
is what we thought would be the best way
to help her you know we feel bad that
she died blah-dee-blah this is the same
way Lisa McPherson died the scientists
night because they have a version of
that called the introspection rundown
yeah
which is like exorcism and she ended up
dying the same yeah they weren't feeding
her giving her water yeah she evidently
she was refusing it she had a psychotic
break yeah we'll see Annalise was
refusing it yeah
but the Scientologists they're gonna do
the introspection rundown is what they
call it it's as a turret it's a way of
exercising alien demonic yeah different
yeah no they believe in demonic
possession oh yeah these are alien
demons with Scientology yeah so she died
like Melissa Macpherson yep so you know
obviously big media trial big you know
trial and the media was all over it
they were arguing whether you know
because her parents and because Annalise
supposedly genuinely believed that she
was possessed by demons and they thought
they were helping her you know were they
still as culpable blah-dee-blah
so that was kind of the argument that
was that went on at the trial now at the
end of the trial all for her parents and
the two priests were found guilty of
manslaughter damn well how much do they
get but not much because they they they
thought that they you know because of
their genuine belief and they said you
know it sucks she should have fed her
you know but you really thought you were
helping her and run the medicine hadn't
been helping her I mean even though the
doctors that they interviewed said you
know had she been on the medication
longer had she been on different ones it
might have you know the outcome might
have been different
but um so yeah they only got six months
in jail which was later suspended and
three years probation and actually the
prosecution had been asking for less
than that they just wanted the priests
to have a fine and then the the parents
to get guilty but not have any jail time
they just wanted to kind of send a
message they didn't necessarily want to
punish them right but um the weird thing
is that two years after Annalise died
her parents wanted it because they had
had her buried so quickly and they
couldn't afford much they wanted to have
her body move to like a nicer coffin
like a nicer area or whatever and so
they petitioned to have her move now
before that happened they got a phone
call or a letter from a german nun who
said that she had had of
vision of Annalise in her coffin and
that her body was not decayed Oh like
sainted you know okay well let's see if
this is true it is not it is they said
when they witnesses who when they moved
the body said and looked just like a
normal rotted body worker and yeah so
this German done was like apparently
trying to get her sainted but you know
now Anna Lisa's grave is like a little
pilgrimage spot in Germany for devout
Catholics now cuz they kind of think she
was although the Vatican are like
totally not demon-possession
yeah that's not possess no totally not
and and it's really kind of sad because
I mean she was obviously very very
mentally ill yeah the photos of her
Horan yeah and you know it's just kind
of sad because it seemed like she was on
a lot of medication she would she did
have psychiatric treatment it wasn't
didn't really seem to be helping her
well but obviously exercising her didn't
help anything either I mean when she
still be alive it Brian I've done that
now she probably died anyway she might
have yeah I think she had bad brains
maybe and it's kind of sad because it
happened pretty suddenly yeah
I mean you know they said she'd been
pretty normal up until she was a
teenager and she suddenly started having
convulsions and then that was all she
wrote
so um okay so we're gonna take another
break right now and then when we come
back I want to mention two other little
cases where murders were involved yeah
these are pretty good from what you told
me yeah I don't know what you bought
these cases alright so we'll be back
after this short break
there's hairs real and imaginary and I
write about them all paranormal
nonfiction or fiction Rochdale
monster Red Menace
the Pretender grace bellwether go to
WWJD ashbrook calm or search Amazon for
the Jenny Ashford author page okay so
the first one I want to talk about is
interestingly as far as I know this is
the only case in American jurisprudence
where the defendant actually tried to
claim demon possession awesome is the
reason that he murdered somebody yeah
now if you guys ever watched the show a
haunting this case was actually not not
the murder part but this case this
haunting was actually dramatized on the
episode called where demons dwell I
remember that one yeah and it's kind of
similar in the beginning but the end of
it's totally different
this happened in 1981 the guy's name was
Arnie Cheyenne Johnson and what ended up
happening this and this is actually
known if you look it up I think it's
even under this on Wikipedia it's called
the devil made me do it case and I do
think the Warrens were involved in this
motto of course cause you know like I
said wherever there's demonic [ __ ] now
initially just like in the in the end
the haunting TV show this family it was
okay it was a woman named Debbie
Glassell and she moved into a rental
house that was owned by her mother this
was in Brooksville Connecticut and she
moved in there with her 11 year old
brother David now David was the first
one affected that was supposedly
quote-unquote possessed okay so the kid
he moves into the house as soon as they
move in he starts screaming and freaking
out and saying he sees an apparition
that looks like a scary old man with
horns hooves jagged teeth and you know
[ __ ] like that she's the devil yeah
pretty much
and he says that this old man told him
that something bad was gonna happen if
they stayed in the house right so you
know his sister is just like you know
whatever kid you're just having
nightmares or what-have-you but um so at
this point you know her and the younger
brother lived in the house she asked her
fiance who was Arnie Cheyenne Johnson
the guy who would eventually murder
somebody she asked him to move in um
just to keep an eye on the kid because
she's like he's having all these
nightmares and I don't know what's
matter with him so so he moved so Artie
moves in and the kid David his
nightmares are getting worse he's having
him all the time and then he's starting
to see the apparition during the day
like when he's awake and he's he's
saying that he called it the Beast man
and he said that the beast man was
threatening to take his soul away yeah
and yeah I remember this episode yeah
yeah yeah and just like just like in the
Robbie Manheim case you know unexplained
scratches and bruises and stuff like
that start turning up on his skin right
so finally Debby the sister she has a
Catholic priest come and bless the house
and as usually happens that made sure
worse you know that they started hearing
funny noises coming from the Attic the
kids started having seizures talking in
multiple voices at once and then he
started quoting the Bible and quoting
Paradise Lost and similar kid was 11 you
know so I'm sure he hasn't read Paradise
you know oh he read it unprompted just
yeah yeah he would just say quartz right
yeah okay so so then this this went on
for a couple weeks then they call in the
warns yeah and of course the Warrens
step in and go yeah kids got 42 demons
the morning - okay yeah all right
specifically thanks Warren
yeah and the Warrens said that okay so
these 42 demons they come in they do the
minor Rite of exorcism which I guess you
can do without Church permission that's
just the freelance exercise
and so they do this and they say we saw
like a black figure appearing next to
the kid Lorraine said she saw the kid
levitating off the bed and she said that
the kid predicted that Arnie would
murder somebody Wow okay
and so actually Lorraine took this [ __ ]
seriously enough that she went to the
police evidently in October of 1980 and
said hey watch this family especially
that Arnie guy cuz might be some trouble
brewing there he might kill a dude you
might get Wow and this is documented
apparently I mean wow yeah so this is
already starting to sound like the
beginnings of a poltergeist case if yes
man cuz yeah sometimes the poltergeist
focus will be able to kind of like get
messages from the future or remote
knowledge they never thinks it's his own
subconscious doing it it's always an
exterior force is telling him this yeah
be it in gel accord amana core ghostly
yeah but so at this point the demon the
42 demons or whatever are still in the
kid now during one of the exorcisms
Arnie who is the sister's fiance yeah
challenges the demon get you know get
out of the kid come get into me okay it
apparently worked apparently a demons
like quebra and he went in God in RT
okay okay so it seemed like like David
was okay after that and then you know
they took him to doctor he was fine and
then Debby the sister and Arnie the
fiance they moved into their own
apartment and this apartment was in a
building named by a owned by a man named
Allen Bono now Arnie was only 19 years
old at the time these are almost all
kids yeah and when they moved to the new
place he started acting all possess e
and [ __ ] too like David had like he
started saying I'm Sienna an old guy
with horns and he was like super
aggressive and he started getting in
trouble with the law a little bit even
though he'd been you know totally fine
before and then yeah he started getting
real aggressive you going to transit
nice I didn't remember what I did or
said in the middle of it and so no this
is weird
what that what if a poltergeist focused
like a kid can't what if he believes
that his poltergeist manifestation in
other words his psychic force has left
his body and he's now imagining it in
somebody else's body can it be like
mental domination over that other person
could be and where that kid's mental
force is causing another person to do
things yeah like you'd control okay be
and it's word may be that myths were
stories of like MIT psychic domination
comes yeah weird or maybe it is a demon
which is that da história come on but
yeah it could be um weird so what ended
up happening so one day Arnie
debby and some other people are at
Debbie worked at a kennel she was a dog
groomer and they were all there and they
all went out to lunch they were there
her Debbie's nine-year-old cousin Mary
was there Arnie's sister Wanda was there
and they all went to they all went to a
bar and the landlord Allen bono got
drunk now when they came back to the
kennel Allen was actin real you know
belligerent he supposedly grabbed the
nine-year-old girl which I don't know
why and Debbie started to intervene and
stuff like that and then Arnie steps up
says you know let go of the kid whatever
like that and then he stabs the dude to
death what yeah
he just stabbed the [ __ ] out of him yeah
so the landlord they took him you know
took him away in an ambulance obviously
and he died a couple hours later Arnie
took off mmm but they found him a couple
hours later a couple miles away so he
thought he was defending the girl I
guess weird okay so the day after the
murder the Lorraine's look and Lorraine
Warren told the police that Arnie was
possessed by a demon and that was why he
had killed the dude of course they also
were gonna work
a book on the case and they were doing a
lecture series so you know sure take
that with a little grain of salt okay so
so already goes to trial and the lawyers
like alright well we'll see if we can do
something with it with the
demon-possession angle and so he tried
to solicit testimony from exorcist
subpoenas of priests who would witness
the exorcisms and you know so but they
never got anything out of it
so arnie tried to enter a plea of not
guilty by recent possession
Wow and the judge was like dude that's
not a thing you can't do that judge
robert callaghan was like that's a big
ol nope
yeah because he's like wait you know
it's demon possession you can't prove
that in a relative law so so are these
lawyers like okay how about self defense
then yeah and that seemed to work out a
little bit better of others yes no
already ended up getting first degree
manslaughter sentenced to 10 to 20 years
but he only served five yeah
so there must have been in other
circumstances he must have thought that
the the little girl was getting molested
by the guy maybe you [ __ ] oh yeah like
that you know yeah little girls hell you
know he's 19 you know kid that he
overrracted yeah it could be I mean
maybe the guy was just farting around
like hey kid and he's like oh yeah
because they said he'd been acting that
audience been acting real aggressive now
a couple years after the trial the
Warrens a strong yeah it's a deadly
chemical um two years after the trial
the morons did put a book out called the
devil in Connecticut and they said they
paid $2,000 of the profits from the book
to the Glassell family however David
Glassell who was the who was 11 year old
kid who so supposedly started the
possession he later sued the Warrens and
the book publishers saying he cited
libel violation of his right to privacy
intentional infliction of emotional
distress the kid while he went to kid
then but David's brother Karl also sued
because in the book the Warrens alleged
that karl was abusive which I guess was
not true and also
painted him as a villain because he did
not believe in demons demons yeah so you
know Karl Karl also claimed that the
Warrens had made up the whole possession
story and said that they were trying to
exploit David's mental illness or
whatever for buck so it should be noted
though that Debbie Glassell and Artie
Cheyenne Johnson are on board with the
demon possession they said [ __ ] totally
happened you know yeah you know he was
kid was possessed Arnie was possessed
wave it was there any physical evidence
of this possession
did they see objects moving did they see
the only kind of poltergeist type
activity was they heard noises like up
in the Attic like [ __ ] was moving around
that's a bad cuz that could be anything
that could be raccoons buddy where's
that raccoon he also had kind of I think
what they call it crypto knowledge yeah
I called where you good yeah because
they yeah they did say that the kid
predicted predicted things and then
Arnie Wade Carter somebody eventually
well I don't know maybe that was just a
gut instinct though yeah it might have
been is like made a mess like yeah I
knew he was a [ __ ] and yeah you
know I don't know what do you think of
that case what do you call hey how you
gonna call that one was that possession
I don't know I'm not really comfortable
good so obviously it like I said I don't
believe in demons
right might have been mental illness was
it poltergeist might have been doesn't
sound like it but doesn't sound physical
because there was another ship moving
around though now no a portation no
asportation right are spk i mean nothing
really like you know like the robbie
Manheim case that the exorcism was based
on I mean that had a lot of culture got
[ __ ] moving around yet a lot of people
saw yeah
are these other ones yeah sounds like a
weak case to me yeah now we're up we're
kind of almost out of time but I just
wanted to mention this one last one
because it also involved a murder and
it's pretty gross okay now this one
happened in in the UK in West Yorkshire
and it happened in 1974 now this guy was
named Mike
tailor and he was I think he was a
butcher actually he'd never been
particularly religious he had a wife
named Christine I think they had five
children and he apparently been totally
normal guy not particularly religious
Christine was kind of religious and she
was in like a you know Christian
Fellowship type group now Michael Taylor
for some reason got it into his head
he's like oh well I should start going
to the church group too and they don't
know if it was because he suddenly you
know found Jesus or because he was
having an affair with the female
preacher I say who ran the group I say
option two yeah I think it's probably
Marie Robinson was her name
so you know they don't know for certain
if they were having an affair but his
wife certainly suspected it and she kind
of you know confronted him at one of the
meetings like hey are you [ __ ] around
with with what's-her-name with Marie and
and then for some reason Michael Taylor
kind of flipped the [ __ ] out and went
after Marie not his wife right he's kind
of like went after it got real
aggressive like he was gonna beat up on
her and stuff like that and so um yeah
like you do okay and so like the other
kagura congregants there whatever's like
hey man chill the [ __ ] out and and he
did chill the [ __ ] out
they gave him an absolution
blah-dee-blah but after that like he
still started acting real weird like
real erratic and [ __ ] like that and um
cracks a hell of a drug I guess so the
local vicar gets a pair of ministers who
were kind of known for their exorcism
duties and I was like hey kind of come
take a look at this guy cuz maybe
there's something the matter was him
they thought he was under the influence
of Satanists not visit which I thought
was a weird thing like at least under
the influence of Satanists I know that's
most of it happens back in the satanic
panic era who's in the 70s thank you
Stephanie Moore almost in England in
England I don't think the England had
the same I don't think they didn't
either
we'll have to John was an American thing
by the way we did a show on that it was
really funny if you haven't listened to
it I'll be back to it in here okay so so
they take this guy to a church and do
that exorcism
exorcism was performed on October 5th
1974 the night and it went kind of
overnight and then it was over in the
early morning hours now they said during
the exorcism
the minister said we drove out over
three dozen spirits including the
spirits of blasphemy lewdness incest
whatever okay lust whatever yeah oh but
they said oh but there's a bunch more
still in there including the spirits of
insanity and murder
now Scientology is a myth yes it's the
same thing there's a whit easier demon
yeah he's like so there's more demon so
you have to come back tomorrow right and
get rid of the insanity and murdered
runs yeah okay but as it turned out he
never did get back for that second
exorcism because after the first
exorcism he supposedly went home a
couple of hours later policeman noticed
a naked man walking down the street
covered in blood okay they asked him
what the deal was he said it's the blood
of Satan okay so they said where do you
live he's all relived they went to his
house and they found his wife Christine
in the house with her face torn off yeah
he had torn out her tongue and her eyes
with his bare hands he had also
strangled their poodle damn the family
dog yes so yeah he had basically torn
his wife's face off with his bare hands
they said it was the grossest shake she
was Satan yes that's what he said that
was the dog yes dogs Barkin while I was
killing a knight to do something about
it but but yeah that's what he said he
said he believed his wife was possessed
by demons and he had to kill her and so
the priest that performed the ecstasy
yeah totally possessed that shit's gonna
happen yeah and actually ended up so
they actually used that as an argument
at a trial and in his trial they're like
not guilty by reason I've been sanded of
course and they slapped him in a state
hospital they took the path of reason
yeah you're just looking crazy yeah yeah
but we'll the weird thing is they put
him in they sent him to Broadmoor which
is a psychiatric hospital he was there
for two years then he got transferred to
another sick
at your hospital another two years but
then they let him out okay now for the
next couple of decades I think was 27
years he didn't commit any more crimes
they said he attempted suicide four
times um and acting kind of funny but um
but then into sput you know he didn't
try to hurt anybody that they know of
but then in 2005 he was arrested again
for sexual assault on a teenager
underage girl and they put him in prison
and he started acting all possess he and
weird again so they put he was just
curious they put him back in this were
there any any accounts of any kind of
paranormal phenomena around the guy yeah
okay no this guy was just probably not
so so really it shows so really in this
show there's only one case that had
paranormal phenomenon associate it's the
famous case yeah
there weren't any others that had
paranormal phenomena associated with
them um yeah well actually there was one
about the Smurl family but like I said
you know we're running out of time right
time that's a big case and that's kind
of a big case like they would do a show
just on that case later on one day yeah
I mean the Warrens were involved in that
one too so I'm not sure how much Eddie I
think it is yeah but that one was the
same kind of thing where there was
poltergeist well the warrants the
warrants were involved in a lot of cases
they were some of under legitimate yeah
it's just the ones where only the
Warrens were they're the ones that kind
of questioned yeah if only the Warrens
were involved in it yeah it's things are
suspect yeah but okay well I guess crap
time so like over an hour so I hope you
enjoyed the show we actually wanted to
get into more stories but they just we
just kept talking and you know how that
happens so if you like the show please
subscribe and thank you to everyone that
has subscribed yeah and you know you can
listen to us at our project radio
download just the audio you can watch us
on youtube subscribe to our YouTube
channel yeah go like our Facebook page
and our Twitter at 13 o'clock podcast
yeah the YouTube shows awesome it's
funny yeah it's got really good
slideshow on it that adds to well I
tried it takes me a long time to do but
yeah well thank you that's very nice
okay so I guess we will
see you guys next week bye-bye
you